hmm here we go this was my opponent if
you go to the channel and you will know
that that is the video that's running
right now
Rhea Lopez are we gonna answer that
again no I'm gonna take something else
enough of that opening so let's try this
what will black throw at me here okay
now big decision time for black Grunfeld
no Kings Indian instead be for f3 Bishop
III Queen D 292 I'm going to do this to
watch over g4 Bishop here
d4 if it doesn't have your attention it
should as both white and black black
should be looking to strike at this
structure in some way and it's gonna be
one of these two guys to do just that so
there we go
I want to be in a position to recapture
with my knight not my bishop if I
recapture my bishop it's accessible to a
knight deployment to c6 and then I have
to react he's a very very important
minor piece to hang on to and I don't
want to have to be reacting to Knight
threats against the dark square bishop
that was the reason for f3 and you could
also say that was the reason for the
timely Knight g2e to move so now what
actually let me play here protect my
bishop this is going to deter black from
playing Queen to b6 now that he's
protected my knight is free to move with
like Knight f5 stuff Queen here is just
not a good idea at all so more
development needed this is a big dummy
right here so if I were just doing a
whole lot of staring at his own pawns
and right now my first thought is what
actually believe it or not my first
thought was that c6 is weakened I see
what black is ready to do develop to b7
but
the weakens this square and I believe
that an ensuing night move here well a
night a white knight on d5 here is
intolerable and so after an eventual
capture I'm able to recapture and maybe
start to pivot on this c6 square and
that is something that really has a lot
of my attention right now because I may
want to play rook c1 and delay castling
just so I could emphasize this weak
point c6 I'm seeing something that might
be accessible to me
rook c1 Bishop d7 night here Knight
takes pawn takes actually it would just
get challenged real quick wouldn't not
well okay there's no rush with that but
my rook is going to be playing to c1 and
I'm not so sure which one belongs there
I'm gonna go with this one there might
be something opening up on this D file
and my F rope might want to play here or
something like if e6 and pawn push my
rook is gonna be well placed there I
really don't want to be playing this
move so let's go with this move instead
Knight takes I capture towards the
center unless I have a good reason not
to I do not have a good reason not to C
takes d5 and then what else
mmm c6 I might want to actually run this
pond up to b5 and then plant a piece
right on that c6 square and once there
it's going to stay there for a long
while and be a tremendous thorn to these
heavy pieces the rooks the Queen so I
think even if both rooks are off the
board that's actually something that
would be pretty good hmm
let's go with this Knight takes pawn
takes I'm looking for b5 and then c6
what's gonna get done is e 6 gonna be
played no it's not that's not happening
should I avoid exchange I might want to
do that
I don't want too much to get simplified
yeah let's I'm going to avoid that
what's making me run with this is just
seeing that I have a space advantage I
have a pawn in the center on one of
these four squares specifically and my
opponent is not so could actually still
run with this move I'm gonna run with it
now maybe there's even like a knight
position here or something in my other
night here and then get to c6 there's no
way to really double okay now we got
this going on okay this is gonna be
brutal I think even with both heavy
pieces off the board and Knight planting
on c6 is gonna be an absolute killer
okay my opponents taking this into
account apparently I can't support it
really so let's give it up
d6 maybe I could target d6 tie game here
huh I think h32 meet like a pond push
with like pushing the Knights away huh
I'm down on time to here so lady floor
oh boy
how do you do here what do you do what
do you do oh yeah do I really want to do
that one no I dropped that pun oh I'm
getting really nervous here well Bishop
here that's kind of stupid maybe it's
not might not be stupid
a bishop here bishop here bishop here
yeah this is this is exceptional right
here not not like an exceptional move
but this is a great exception to its
it's not typical I don't think I'm
looking to actually just give my bishop
up even if that bishop is still around
I'm seeing that my knight on c6 will
maybe be better than the bishop on e5
that's why I'm running with this line
but well crap I gotta watch out because
the Bishop's gonna kill me right here oh
I missed that one who gets the last
laugh is my opponent laughs laughing
let's do this it's a little scary over
here cuz this pawn is gonna go down in
flames at any moment he's gonna be
cooked although I'm ready to maybe do
this move 44 ticks less than a minute
for party rocker F for kill the bishop
kill the knight 94-96
remove that Ohio most mouse slipped that
would have been bad news watch out for
those Mouse lips I want my night to get
here and then everything is gonna be
nice and cosy
I think Knight right here
is queen g7 gonna be played or something
I think I'll play f4 yeah and then I'll
take the night and that my Brooker might
not really want my night to get here
whoa whoa whoa I'm gonna do it it's
scary but I'm gonna do it
Bishop check and then take the rook I
think my King would much rather be here
let's recapture it's definitely scary
look at this dummy right here
my LightSquared Bishop is the big dummy
I got a premie about 37 seconds my
opponent better I kick it into higher
gear less than a minute
Oh what do you do what do you do what do
you do when you're not coordinated oh
that's just a flat-out blunder oops
uh time pressure get the best of black
there what pressure the pressure was
mounting but what a tight game whoa
good game let me back up here let's have
a look at this one and see how either
one of us could have done one better so
let's see good game I agree
no doubt let's see backing up so Kings
Indian setup huh so far so book this is
I wonder well I wonder about the b6 move
maybe I could have been doing some other
stuff
well no no well like when b6 is played I
already have like again I was focused on
c6 a great deal and the piece never
quite got there but it really influenced
things in this game this weakness on c6
it really made black think again about
chopping this Knight once it played to
d5 so I wonder if just a bishop move to
d7
or even to e6 seeing how if I capture
you recapture you're getting a couple
things half-open F file and control over
d5 which means this night is not going
to have a good post so I think
considering one of these - I think
Bishop e6 might be the way to go here at
least something to be looking into yeah
I mean I wasn't able to to really do
that I mean my opponent was being
stubborn with the capture on d5 maybe I
was uh maybe I shouldn't have done that
not sure I didn't want too many pieces
to be exchanged cuz I wanted I wanted to
have more pieces on the board and having
a piece on that square but just wasn't
happening was it take irie capture I
think II six is a good move now that my
night is a bit displaced now I'd really
be liking to have him on d4 at this very
moment it's just not working though I do
that now I'm losing a pond and before I
can really get to this square this is
the other thing now that I have now that
I'm capturing away I don't have as much
of a grip on c6 my opponent has a
half-open F file and this night I can't
I just I can't kick it away so easily
right F for not only dropping the pond
but there's even night G four
possibilities that wasn't the intent I
had with this earlier f3 move - just
watch over g4 so if I'm pushing it I'm
making that available yet again I think
this was a very good game by Black here
this Bishop move hmm well maybe my
bishop idea was not the right thing to
do but I am concerned right now about
about just a break in the center this
guy didn't do anything I mean he ended
up winning I mean getting the Queen at
the end but other than just being
serving a defensive role it's really not
doing a whole lot I'd much rather have
him on like b3 pointing at the king
right now but things blew up here didn't
die and I think the night the night move
I wonder if I wonder if Queen here and
then like some sack on this Square and
then Queen coming out to H for something
is a good idea I don't know but it's it
was definitely a really good game very
interesting a lot of resistance play put
up by black recognizing the strong
points now capturing on d5 I think
showed a pretty good understanding of
data pawn structure right there and what
what exactly was going on so great very
good